ça va mal et comme je remercie en cas
d'exploit pour l'invitation je suis très
heureux d'être parmi vous d'otages leur
présence et versailles mort je vais
alléger leurs deux formations politiques
ni sciages bien cher de chefs
d'entreprise à manager enseignants
universités aussi donc je remercie mon
précieux temps monsieur ali malek
console excellent show et là parler du
développement
c'est vrai que c'est un homme c'est un
certain discours qui est très très
sensible
parlons du développement sachant que
l'algérie fait partie du globe terrestre
comme tous les pays pratiquement et à
260 270 qui sont qui sont reconnus par
l'onu et le développement c'est c'est
relativement parlant c'est une question
de qui est relatif on ne peut pas
définir c'est quoi le développement donc
le moule qu'on vit le monde
bush il bouge très très vite et dès fois
on aperçoit qu il en train de bouger est
content si on parle du du développement
comme un indic homme a parlé déjà
monsieur malek déjà toute l'humanité a
participé au développement
commençons par les ados les musulmans
les musulmans de les musulmans de l'asie
les musulmans de l'espagne l'andalousie
les applis car il ya des tribus en
afrique il était très très développé les
occidentaux les américains les français
les européens
et si on parle économiquement parlant et
avait fin d année ou bien les années que
19ème siècle il y avait il y avait comme
on dira je la révolution industrielle
donc on a proposé des modèles des
modèles économiques commence on parlera
pas représentée par le terrorisme qui a
présenté la la
la chasse scientifique et puis il faut
10 la chaîne de production
et puis après la deuxième guerre
mondiale on avait le lean le lean
management et les le house management
si on part si on prend le cas de
l'algérie parce que c'est 1 l'algérie 5
ans en mai l'école donc après
l'indépendance on a on a adopté on a
adopté un système un système déjà on
sait pas si on adopte un système par
défaut ou bien par la souveraineté et
parfois par besoin donc après
l'indépendance bien sûr le premier
challenge c'était 1972 c'était la
nationalisation des hydrocarbures qui a
été fait par
vergogne leurs mots et puis on se posait
la question à l'époque à ce qu'on a fait
ça par souveraineté ou bien on a fait ça
a pas besoin et à l'époque on disait que
attention c'est temporaire
attention c'est temporaire c'est à dire
ses effets maps est éphémère c'est à
dire ça va pas durer dans le temps et
juste dix ans après ou bien douze ans
après ça commençait la crise en 84 puis
on avait le le système économique à
l'époque
l'économie dirigée par l'état à vue à
vue il était en ruine au wynn et puis on
a proposé d'autres proposer d'autres
systèmes économiques
c'était le capitalisme et la miami 90 le
problème que la gérer a eu par rapport à
la décennie noire mais par rapport à
l'endettement parlera par la famille
donc on a on a décidé de de parcourir à
nouveau un nouveau challenge c'était on
a essayé de rentrer au capitalisme mais
malheureusement on a fait les choses
dans des circonstances un peu
particulières et on a mal fait les
choses
actuellement on essaie de rectifier la
trajectoire on essaye de corriger le tir
en proposant d'autres systèmes
c'est vrai que ça fait pratiquement
indies une dizaine d'années une décennie
qu'on parle d'un start up on parle d'un
et qu'un nouveau un nouvel écosystème
qui les startups l'entrepreneuriat la
question qui se pose est ce que ces
systèmes frau vraiment est bénéfique
pour l'algérie
on sait pas on sait pas jusqu'à jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
parce que c'est vrai ce qui a été fait
et ce qui a été réussi à l'extérieur
n'est pas forcément n'est pas forcément
d'actualité en ag je parle de ma de ma
demande l'expérience de ma simple
expérience dans ma toute petite
expérience
quand on a commencé le canton a commencé
l'écosystème
en 2010 deux mille 2000 2012 2012
on disait toujours que cet aspect là va
apporter à apporter quelque chose par
rapport ce qui a été déjà fait c'est à
dire pour les entreprises que soient les
entreprises publiques ou bien les autres
aux biens les entreprises privées et
l'investigation qu'on a fait c'est que
les entreprises publiques avait avait du
mal avait du mal à exprimer le besoin
par rapport à besoin client besoins
clients même les fondamentaux du
marketing en changer on parlait de
marketing marketing que la sig les 4p
actuellement on est les 4 d c'est à dire
à la base on avait on crée le besoin
pour le client mais actuellement on est
en train de s'adapter aux besoins du
client
et puis sa démarche là là la vue à la
vue
ou bien elle a trouvé ses limites par
rapport à ça et par rapport à ça donc on
est revenu aux fondamentaux comme a déjà
a dit le cheikh malek
donc on est dans les fondamentaux donc
on a vu pourquoi on a changé de système
si on commence par le terrorisme
pourquoi on a changé les systèmes et
l'horizon dans le verdissement vers le
lean est actuellement la les années 70
80 on a vu la naissance d'un nouveau
système qui sont les entreprises 3.0 ou
bien les entreprises libéré et
actuellement on parle d entreprise agit
alors c'est quoi les entreprises
agissent et des entreprises qui sont pas
des start up
ils sont pas des micro entreprises mais
qui sont des entreprises du cours et
leurs particularités c'est qu'ils
adaptent avec l'écosystème fixé à
n'importe quelle étape on essaie de
faire on essaie d'introduire cette
expérience feu me now bien le nord
afrique c'est pas vraiment c'est pas
vraiment quelque chose de 2,2 facile
messieurs on part du principe la gestion
des projets bien la gestion des
opérations au bien la gestion d aider
des entreprises au pont long terme
managériale on trouve une interaction
entre ces systèmes
je vais m'expliquer c'est à dire par
avant on avait des entreprises qui qui
qui ont d une vingtaine ou une trentaine
d'employés et puis on n'arrive pas à
gérer par rapport à par rapport à un
système est qui et qui a une archi
pratiquement fonctionnel et actuellement
on est dans un système où on gère
beaucoup plus des organigrammes qui sont
plutôt qu'ils sont plutôt matricielle et
puis les années 2000 deux mille pardons
les années 2000 on a vu la naissance d
des petites entreprises qui sont pas des
start up a forcément des starters parce
que pour dire qu'une entreprise c'est
une start up c'est trop beau c'est vrai
que tout le monde actuellement on parle
des start up il faut faire des start up
c'est comme si les start up ou bien la
start up ou bien cet écosystème c'est
c'est vraiment la bouffée d'oxygène
alors qu'on se trouve actuellement
parce que pour moi il faut déjà sauvé ce
qu'on a
il ya des entreprises déjà privée
romaine entreprise est public qui ont
beaucoup de problèmes
on peut citer le cas par exemple de lune
y en a ça fait pratiquement une semelle
de sa qui ont repris qui ont repris le
travail
ils étaient en chômage technique donc
actuellement je pense que le challenge
c'est de sauver ce qui a sauvé et puis
de proposer un nouveau système pour une
nouvelle économie et pour cela si on
prend les nouveaux systèmes comme j'ai
dit de l'agilité c'est à dire on
travaille d'une façon flexible on
travaillait façon flexible pour trois
challenges le premier chalet s'est déjà
galets un client bien gagner les clients
le design challenge fr chiffre
d'affaires et le 3e challenge c'est
faire un bénéfice et pour cela il faut
trouver des défauts capter des nouveaux
créneaux et comptant cap des nouveaux
créneaux
il faudra les propulser vers l'avant
si on parle des grandes entreprises par
exemple en france ou bien en europe qui
sont très coté en bourse
ils sont en train de voir cette
stratégie là pour donner et donner un
autre une autre dimension
alors à l'heure à venir maintenant le
cas de la jirs c'est toujours le même
problème le cadre de la gérer où sommes
nous est ce que le challenge
actuellement c'est de voir la challe ou
de voir les maillots ou là un moyen de
la chaîne
si on parle côté start up je pense que
c'est nu
ce n'est qu'un moyen de mal
il faut trouver des nouveau challenge
pour par rapport à ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui
mais il faut réagir en agilité lundi
comme je viens de l'agilité c'est de
réagir aux montres flexion c'est à dire
on est flexible on fait des ce qui a été
fait déjà part avon on peut prendre et
ce qui n'a pas été fait on peut le
corriger
maintenant ça reste la taille de
l'entreprise si on a des entreprises qui
sont à la fois une dizaine ou une
vingtaine de une vingtaine de n'employer
ya pas de problème c'est gérable
maintenant si on part au delà c'est à
dire une cinquantaine ou bien au plus il
faudra adapter ce qu'on appelle
l'agilité à l'échelle c'est à dire les
les méthodologies ancien dans les termes
de l'agilité c'est pas vraiment c'est
pas vraiment le bon choix c'est à dire
comment la trouver des nouveaux moyens
comme le scrabble ou bien le scrabble de
scrabble ici on doit proposer un nouveau
moyen d'un pilotage comme le cerf par
exemple escalade j'ai le frac mois et
puis la capture c'est par rapport aux
clients c'est le client qui définit le
besoin ces panneaux qui crée le besoin
et par rapport à ça on va les grandes
entreprises qui sont quand j'ai dit
qu'ils sont très très coté en bourse et
qui ont un portefeuille clients aux
biens portefeuille manager qui est très
important est ce que on peut adapter
cette méthodologie des fois oui des fois
non si on prend la plus grande
entreprise de l'afrique par exemple la
sonatrach
je pense que la meilleure méthode c'est
la méthode hybride c'est-à-dire on prend
ce qui a été proposé auparavant avec les
nouvelles modalités et on peut faire une
fusion parce que déjà même le système
économique algérien était basée sur les
hydrocarbures un certain monde dans les
années 70 ses débuts des années 80 et
puis la crise économique de la de 1984
et puis jusqu'en 1900 la deuxième crise
prolin de la famille et puis on a oublié
de faire les choses
2002 2003 c'était le bout il y avait
tout marche
donc on a oublié deux apporter des
corrections
on s'est oubliée et actuellement on
s'est retrouvé dos au mur notre doit
rapporter quelque chose on doit apporter
des nouveaux challenge est pour cela que
ce soit dans un système ou bien dans un
système économique basé sur
l'hydrocarbure dont il faudra se
position est-ce qu'on est un pays
producteur est ce qu est ce qu on est un
pays producteur
est-ce qu'on est un pays producteur
exportateur espionner un pays
consommateur donc ans est arrivé à une à
une à une réponse connaît un pays
actuellement on est un pays exportateur
mais malheureusement un pays
consommateur et pour cela la vend du
pétrole
ce n'est qu'une histoire ancienne c'est
à dire il faudra trouver des nouveaux
moyens pour protéger l'économie et pas
trouver de nouveaux gisements tels que
le gaz de schiste et ce n'est pas le gaz
de schiste ici on propose les gaz de
schiste c'est pas parce que la france a
laissé tomber le gaz de schiste qu'on
devrait laisser tomber le gaz de schiste
parce que si on prend les gaz de schiste
les états unis à des flammes et a dégagé
schiste parce que le problème c'est le
problème de la méthode
et ce n'est pas le problème du produit
lui même donc je pense qu'il faut passer
il faut corriger le système qui existe
actuellement
et puis trouver des nouveaux challenges
je vous remercie de votre attention et
que sarah